لذا فهذه مشكلة عالمية ، لذا فهي ليست
مجرد توقعات بـ 100 نفط ، بل إنها
زيادات هائلة في أسعار الغاز الطبيعي ، حتى أن
تكاليف الفحم ترتفع بشكل كبير ،
أوصلنا أولاً إلى ما يسبب هذا ، وإذا كانت
هناك نهاية تلوح في
الأفق حسنًا ، مثل كل شيء
آخر العرض الآن هو  فقط عدم
مواكبة الطلب أه رأينا
أه طلب على عودة الطاقة
لأن الناس يسافرون أكثر
إنهم يقودون أكثر إنهم يتنقلون أه
المشكلة أنه سواء كان الفحم أو
الغاز الطبيعي أو النفط
لم يستمر  أعتقد أن هناك
الكثير من الأسباب التي تجعلنا
نلقي نظرة على النفط على صعيد العرض ، لا تزال منظمة أوبك الأولى
تحبط الكثير من البراميل
التي استخرجت كمية غير مسبوقة من
الإنتاج
مرة أخرى في مارس وأبريل 2020
وكان التدريجي بطيئًا للغاية لإعادة تلك
البراميل.
نفس الشيء بالنسبة لنا النفط ، لقد كان أيضًا
بطيئًا في إعادة الإنتاج
عندما تنظر إلى الفحم ، فنحن نعلم أن الفحم
قد أصبح غير محبوب
لدى العديد من الحكومات في جميع أنحاء العالم
ولا يُنظر إليه على أنه  اقتصاديًا
وقد رأينا الكثير من محطات الطاقة
تتحول بعيدًا عن الفحم ، فقد ذهبوا إلى
الغاز الطبيعي ومصادر الطاقة المتجددة بدلاً من
ذلك ، والآن هناك بالفعل
حاجة أكبر للفحم ، لذلك رأينا ارتفاع أسعار الفحم
ثم هناك  هناك
جزء من الغاز الطبيعي
هو حقيقة أن إنتاج النفط ينخفض
دما تنتج النفط تنتج كم
ة معينة من الغاز الطبيعي أه أيضًا رأ
نا أحداثًا متعلقة بالطقس أه لم
كن هناك نفس القدر أه من الرياح القوية في
وروبا  وهذا يضر
أه جيل الرياح والشيء الآخر
مع أه الغاز الطبيعي
هو أن تتذكر أنك تعرف أن روسيا
لاعب كبير على جبهة الغاز الطبيعي
وروسيا في الواقع تصدر
غازًا طبيعيًا أقل اليوم إلى أوروبا مما كانت عليه
في  عام 2019 و IEA مؤخرًا
دعا روسيا بشكل أساسي وقالوا إنهم يعتقدون
أن روسيا يمكن أن تفعل المزيد آه لذلك علينا أن
نرى ما إذا كان فلاديمير بوتين قرر محاولة
إرسال المزيد من النفط
لامتصاص المزيد من الغاز الطبيعي إلى أوروبا أم
لا